rachel has a big meryl streep surprise
that is right ricardo
you know we have all heard meryl sing
but there is much more
to her musical talent
stranger things have happened in 2020
but
meryl streep the rapper what gotta wear
your crown or your tiara
oh i rap all the time of course you do
right
freestyle you know i was yeah at home
meryl rapid plus a-listers kerry
washington nicole kidman and james
gordon all in one film
yep it's called the prom the story line
is about a girl in a conservative small
town
fighting for the right to go to prom
with her girlfriend and some washed up
broadway stars arrive to help
we have got to go down there yes raise
holy hell
we will be the biggest thing to happen
in indiana since
whatever's happened in indiana bad
reviews that's something that
your characters are heavily impacted by
what is
a rule of the past that you feel like a
review has really stuck with you
a very famous critic wrote a very bad
review of a film i did called
sophie's choice and she said that i
should
giggle more and cry less
and i've taken that criticism to heart
and i sort of agree with her james and
you oh
i got too many to even think about
really that's what i say to you i'm from
britain so
a lot of the time in great britain
you're either the king of the world
or you're dead and over and uh the trick
is to realize that neither of those
things are true
[Music]
in the musical rom-com streaming
december 11th on netflix
keegan michael key gets to lock lips
with three-time oscar winner
merrell dude where does that ring on
like
your past kisses on screen it's hands
down
i is i don't know how is it zero how do
you go above one is it a plus one
whatever the new map is and you go above
meryl's character in the film she plops
a couple of trophies down
on the counter at the hotel to hopefully
get an upgrade
in her room surely you know who i am
have you ever called the celebrity card
karen no i'm usually having to like tell
my family members
not to pull the celebrity card because i
don't want to get that call to be like
your dad was in here the other day
i'm like oh my gosh i'm sorry
who are you people well carrie's dad
isn't the only one to benefit from her
star
status so do her kids i'm getting a lot
of joy from that artwork behind you miss
carrie
they get so excited when we have
entertainment tonight on and they're
like i did that
that's my heart i'm like there you are
girl you're up there
you